Death is not the end they are still with us
as long as we do not forget them.
Welcome back everyone this to be my full marvel
What If episode 5 video for marvel zombies.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs to marvel
comics.
It's a big story line they're doing from the
comics based around the events of Avengers
Infinity War perfectly balanced is all zombie
universes should be if you're new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes this season
They've already confirmed that they're going
to do what if season two.
And hopefully release those episodes next
year as well.
Careful for spoilers if you have not seen
this episode yet will be talking about everything
will start at the beginning and work our way
through shot by shot talk about Easter eggs
and moments and there were many moments probably
one of the biggest things about this episode.
Aside from just the fact they're actually
doing.
The zombies storyline is it is the first canonical
time in the MCU that someone has uttered the
name uncle Ben Spider-Man no less.
Like he literally mentions uncle Ben out loud
during the end of the episode.
He also references his dead parents, which
I think is also an MCU first when he was talking
about this during Captain America Civil War.
He never actually said uncle Ben's name out
loud to Iron Man.
He just references that.
Saying bad things happen sometimes, but he
never said the words uncle Ben.
So this is the first time that he did that,
but if you're not familiar with marvel zombies
is sort of an elseworlds type of story noncanonical
to the main 616 marvel universe.
But would you be surprised if I said that
the original marvel zombies storyline was
written by Robert Kirkman of walking dead
fame in obviously.
The physics of how marvel zombies work how
they exist is very different from the walking
dead version of zombies or zombies the you
see during other franchises.
I was a the way the marvel zombies work way
you explain how their powers their abilities
work is very similar to the zombies of Zack
Snyder's day of the dead franchise.
Like army of the dead like a very fast, highly
cognitive version of zombies, because in the marvel universe
the zombies can still use all the powers that
they had when they were still alive or their
abilities like Iron Man can still use all
this armor the same way Doctor strange and
one can so use their spells the same way Scarlet
witch can use her powers the same way it even
though they don't really do that much during
this episode marvel zombies can still talk
somewhat albeit altered slurred kind of speech
in within marvel comics the marvel zombies
storyline becomes a multiverse storyline.
Like this what if is a multiverse storyline
spitting out of the Loki series.
Even though at the end of the episode.
The watcher only references them taking this
version of the universe.
Like this universe will turn into zombies,
but they don't reference it spilling into
another universe in the comics, the marvel
zombies do start traveling the multiverse,
converting the rest of the multiverse into
zombies.
But the watcher narrates the intro.
Explaining the very different version of Avengers
Infinity War.
Explaining what would've happened if the whole
came back being sent by the bifrost back to
earth by heimdall.
But finding that the earth, that turned into
a version of marvel zombies.
When he returned because of what happens with
Janet van dyne in the quantum virus inside
the quantum realm there are a couple minor
changes to the main MCU timeline here.
But for the most part up to the events of
Captain America Civil War everything played
out the exact same way that it did during
the original marvel movies if it wasn't clear
pretty much all of the MCU actors came back
to voice their characters.
There were only a couple exceptions in obviously
a couple of them.
Don't talk like scarlet witch didn't speak
Iron Man didn't speak like Chadwick postman
came back to do this version of Black Panther
Paul bettany came back to do vision evangeline lilly
came back to do the wasp Danai Gurira
came back to do Okoye.
Even Jon Favreau came back to the voice of
Happy Hogan Sebastian Stan came back again
to do this version of Bucky.
But if you couldn't tell this is not tom Holland
doing the voice of this version of Spider-Man
the zombie Hunter Spider-Man I believe.
Because tom Holland was too busy filming his
movies last year.
Like he was filming both Spider-Man no way
home and the uncharted movie back to back
so that he was just too busy to come to the
voice for this.
But Mark Ruffalo is also back is the hulk
remember he showed up during episode three
during the events of the incredible hulk for
that version of the avengers story.
So he was playing the Edward Norton's version
of the whole during that episode.
But this time because were up to the events
of Avengers Infinity War were into full Mark
Ruffalo era hulk.
So he crashes to the sanctum just like he
did during avengers Infinity War it make another
walking dead reference is like New York City
has gone full Atlanta from season one.
When Rick Grimes came to Atlanta if this massive
cityscape but no one is there.
It just super quiet they that same funny scene
of the Holt not wanting to come out when ebony
monocle obsidian come down from the queue
ship remember event still play a pretty similarly
to what they did during avengers Infinity
War on the thanos side of things at least
up until the end of the episode that big twist
reveal, except this time Doctor strange opens
a portal in this is a bit of a reference to
avengers endgame with the portal scene they
play the big avengers theme the same way they
play the portals theme song whenever was coming
to the portals.
But it's a very dark twist on that scene because
they come from their zombies.
Even though they obscure their faces.
So you can see like Holt also says you guys
are totally screwed out, which is another
reference to when Thor arrived during avengers
Infinity War him you like you are all screwed now
I love the way they play this for some dark
humor to like get a little overkill their
guys as you ask you kind of see them gnawing
on the black order turning them into zombies
to the do the full reveal with Doctor strange
cloak of levitation saving him from the marvel
zombies using some of the same tricks from
the thanos battle on Titan the cloak is even
able to kill zombie Wong.
So go cloak RIP Wong very creative use of
portals chomping his head off in like a said
just from the way they behave you can kind
of tell the way marvel zombies work they can
use all their abilities.
They move really fast they just hunger for
human flesh, then the horde of ants from ant-man
the wall shows up to clean up the rest of
the zombies consuming Doctor strange the black
order wasp reveals herself kills Iron Man
then saves hulk with the cloak of levitation,
and Spider-Man shows up very similar to the
way that he showed up to save Iron Man during
the original avengers Infinity War movie,
you notice the watcher silhouette shows up
against the sky and explains how this return
in the marvel zombies doing the big flashback
to Janet van dyne and hank him during the
events of ant-man the wasp so the whole idea
here is that Janet van dyne was patient zero
for this universes marvel zombies outbreak
the interesting thing to is that there's only
one quantum realm of the multiverse.
So theoretically she could have exited the
quantum realm that any random universe or
point in that timeline in that universe that
she would've come out and it would've become
the first marvel zombies universe and theoretically
through the use of their quantum technology
the real threat here is that the marvel zombies
should have the ability to spread through
the multiverse civil wasn't clear this wasn't
somebody mysteriously creating the zombie
virus and then giving it to her.
She contracted it naturally.
It just like a cork of the quantum realm there
is a very dark version of that reunion scene
from ant-man the wasp when Hank Pym and Janet
van dyne come out of the quantum realm there
ship hope is obvious able to heat herself
away before she's bit but they said the whole
head in a jar Scott Lang by having him get
bit.
Just not on his head all the way vision explains
it later, he did turn into a zombie and then
he changed him back using the mind stone.
But the reason why he wound up being a head
in a jar is because he was only experimenting
on human brain so he didn't need the rest
of Scotland's body to try and cure him is
also kind of imply that Hank Pym it a giant
chunk of the rest of his body to then as the
watcher says within about 24 hours the entire
Pacific Northwest section of the United States
have been turned into zombies and is a coy
a then later explains within the matter of
a couple weeks.
The rest of the planet have been covered in
zombies all but Wakanda because of their big
shield at least apparently until Thanos showed
up with 5 of the infinity stones, but he explains
that was basically the avengers that, inadvertently
doomed the planet.
Because there so powerful whose gonna stop
the avengers.
Even though there are a couple other avengers
who are alive during the episode.
It just allows them to quickly spread the
virus because they still have all their abilities
as the avengers when they been turned you
notice that they're mostly wearing their avengers
Infinity War costumes with a couple big exceptions
so Hawkeye is there and he's not under house
arrest and Black Panther is with them wearing
a version of his suit from Captain America Civil War
Like they're saying that in this universe,
the avengers either never broke up.
Like they never had their civil war to begin
with.
Or at least it did in his badly for them as
it did in the main MCU universe.
But they reveal the Black Panther actually
survive for little while up in San Francisco
like is it was Chadwick Boseman coming back
to the voice of this Black Panther the way
he explains the the timeline for Black Panther
in the episode is that they get attacked in
then a little while later.
Like Black Panther survives that are manages
to survive eventually the zombie outbreak
spreads scarlet witch gets infected then that's
when vision comes and rescues critical are
kind of risk is but not really rescues Black
Panther from the San Francisco area so that
he can slowly feed bits of Black Panther to
zombie scarlet witch probably one of the bigger
moment from the episode.
Apparently Black Panther is now on the menu
they do the big Spider-Man rules montage with
them play it like Spider-Man made a home movie.
Like a YouTube video that he produced himself
for the rules of how to survive a zombie apocalypse
it plays a lot like the scene from Spider-Man
homecoming with him cosplaying as the different
avengers just play acting pretending to be
the other avengers also big deal here you
notice the in the video.
He's filming himself without his mask on.
So whoever's theoretically watching this will
learn his secret identity.
But not that it matters that much, because
as they explained pretty much the entire world
is turned into zombies and he's only expecting
the other avengers characters or people that
they rescue to be on their team to watch this
video.
So his secret identity is the least of his
worries here.
I also thought it was a little weird that
he reference sex and the city when talking
about New York City.
I was he the show takes place in New York
City, just seems weird that a teenager like
Spider-Man, even though he's a pop-culture
junkie with think of sex and the city first
when he's thinking of New York City that he
uses happy Hogan for rule number one and it
is Jon Favreau who came back to do the voice
rule number one is always wear long sleeves
because the virus is pastor saliva not the
actual bites themselves.
Which is why the hulk doesn't immediately
turn at the end of the episode when Benner
almost gets bit on his arm.
But the hulk hulks out to save him, you notice
is got happy wearing one of the funny T-shirts
saying I'm not single I'm saving myself for
Thor, you also see that he's wearing the gauntlet
from one of Iron Man's suits they wind up
using that for the blame joke later in the episode
There's a joke about him not actually being
happy in his skills are driving because he
started out as Iron Man chauffeur boxing,
because in the comics happy Hogan started
out as a professional boxer before he became
Tony Stark chauffeur they kind of referenced
that in the MCU movies during Iron Man two
with that funny scene of him and black widow
in the boxing ring where she kicks his ass
then Kurt comes in from the ant-man movies
and it is David Doss Moshe and coming back
to do his voice most of the marvel movie actors
came back for this just a couple exceptions
reason why says Slavic folklore in crime are
his skills are because he's the one who was
yelling about Bob a young God during ant-man
of the wasp when go showed up and he also
references that again later in the episode
talking about the, which Bobby Iago mythological
he.
But as a reference to scarlet witch who shows
up as a zombie later the crime skill is a reference
Because ant-man's crew ex-con security was
a group of ex-convicts who used to pull heist together
Rule number two.
They use winter soldier which Bobby see a
different version from the Bucky that we saw
during episode one.
Rule number two is keeping a personal hygiene
because zombies are attracted the smell of human flesh
He's a be super pitstop because they were
trying to surprise him in the shower.
But you notice the curtain is decorated with
the captain America flag pattern because he's
a captain America character.
His skills are murder it is the vibranium
version of his arm from Black Panther Spider-Man
calls him silent but deadly because winter
soldier doesn't really talk that much is scalpels
most of the time in the joke about him being
a heavy sleeper is just a reference to him
being in cryo storage for so long when shuri
was deprogramming and because from the events
of falcon and winter soldier we've seen is
PTSD causes him to have really bad sleep problems
they make all kinds of puns.
Kurt makes a about his arm being super handy
later when head in a jar Scott Lang shows up
It just all puns wall to wall the you Sharon
Carter for rule number three.
Always aim for the head.
Which you could also call another Thor versus
thanos avengers Infinity War reference you
should have gone for the head also a pretty
much every zombie related story, regardless
of which kind of zombie you're talking about
head shots are usually the only way to stop
them obviously, because in the timeline here.
This version of Sharon Carter has not become
the power broker yet Spider-Man calls her
the blonde bond as in James Bond because her
skills are spy craft in the MCU.
She was a shield agent first day because she
help patch up team captain America during
Civil War and eulogies because she also gave
Peggy Carter's eulogy during Civil War then
they do that funny transition with a coy a
yelling at him, transitioning from them showing
hulk watching the video.
Like the perspective of hope watching the
video to them inside the train car base.
She introduces herself to banner very similar
to the scene of the meeting during avengers infinity war
She said she swore an oath to fight the outbreak
a couple weeks ago after Black Panther disappeared.
She says he went missing which is meant to
foreshadow the big twist where you find that
he still alive at the end of the episode they
have a joke about the beacon coming on the
wires revealing the Spider-Man has uses webbing
to create this base made up of train cars
suspended in midair between the New York City
high-rises does they're using one of Iron
Man's gauntlets is a projection device and
they decode that the person who they think
has a cure for the virus is hold up in Camp
Lehigh, New Jersey, which is the original
base from the first captain America movie
where he trained before getting the super soldier serum
It was where they were keeping the Tesseract
during the 1970s and the shield base in avengers
endgame during the heist that was where Howard
Stark young Hank Pym and Arnim Zola were doing
their research and later in Captain America
Winter soldier the same place of Arnim Zola
had uploaded his consciousness into the computer
database effect in present day vision is using
that same computer terminal bank for some
of his research the reason why happy Hogan
makes the New Jersey joke like New Jersey
sucks joke is because Jon Favreau in real
life is from New Jersey if I thresh a ton
of high-level marvel people that are from New Jersey
Like Kevin Feige himself is also from New
Jersey they've a bunch of jokes about happy
being a chauffeur a coy a calls him an uber
driver know it's a chauffeur it's different
they do the same joke from ant-man and the
wasp with them making the car big again to
take out one of the zombies when they take
these to Grand Central this is a big reference
to avengers Infinity War and the original
avengers movie the area that they're in right
here is near where the original avengers tower
used to be Spider-Man search referencing the
rules of horror movies.
Because a coy he wants to split the teams
up later she apologizes for trying to split them up
It even though she says they don't need horror
movies and Wakanda because they have American
reality shows, which I think is a reference
to survivor because they're literally trying
to survive here we actually do have horror
movies and Wakanda as they explained during
the Black Panther movie their father was is
huge fan of pop-culture movies.
Like shuri says that he was a huge fan of
back to the future because she makes the sneakers
just like the sneakers from back to the future
to so they been watching those kinds of movies
they've also probably seen a lot of the big
popular horror movies as well.
Heavy gets attacked by a bunch of birds foreshadowing
the falcon attack when Sharon Carter makes
fun of him for same plan out loud when he
fires iron man's hand cannon this is a she
bit of a meta joke about actors in real life
on the marvel movies a lot of times will happen
is because the guns on movie sets don't make
the regular sounds that normal guns would
make in real life when the actors are firing
there fake guns in these action scenes though
make the sounds out loud sometimes, which
is that she really ballads are not supposed
to do that then the sounds of the guns and
postproduction later on.
They also use the bland joke to set the reversal
when she kills him using the hand cannon in
the takes it for herself using against zombie
Hawkeye and says blame herself kind of a sad
lamb they went up using Spider-Man's webbing
to create a massive slingshot to get the train moving
and like I said I just reference the Spider-Man
2 train fight this is sort of like a reverse
version of that like using the tensile strength
of his webbing to make it go instead of trying
to stop it, then the cloak of levitation save
Spider-Man and wasp references him growing
into the Cape look like looks good on you
kid, which is a reference to Spider-Man wearing
a cape in the comics briefly they also did
a version of that joke during Spider-Man into
the spider verse like Spider-Man does not
wear a cape.
But they also find a Kate version of his costume
from the comics later inside Spider-Man slayer
zombie Captain America, winds up taking out
Sharon Carter RIP in they kind of do a set
up line for I could do this all day when winter
soldier says I think you've had enough Than
the winter soldier's end of the line dialogue
is actually a reference to all the captain
America movies during all the captain America
movies, there's a different version of the
end of the line phrase the each one of them
mentions to each other in its references and
sticking together helping each other till
the end of the line till they die.
Thus in killing zombie Captain America.
It also doing it on a train.
This is metaphorically and literally the end
of the line, he also takes Out using the same
trick from Captain America Winter soldier
where he catches the shield then reverses
it on a wall wasp takes out zombie Sharon
Carter using a modified version of the sanest
method going in her mouth will call that a
reverse famous the twist being that she was
infected while this happened in only has a
little while before the virus turns her as
they continue to Lehigh you see the watcher
silhouette up against the skylight again to
watch it and there's a ton of great Spider-Man
scenes here with hope van dyne.
Maybe we'll see them get some scenes together
in the live action movies, during Avengers 5
The like is that during this scene Spider-Man
also mentions the name uncle been out loud
for the first time in the MCU and his dead
parents out loud, he also reveals during the
speech that aunt May has turned into a zombie.
At this point.
Hope winds up sacrificing herself going giant
to get them past the war in this is actually
a big comic book reference to giant woman
in the comics, Janet van dyne the original
wasp became giant woman for appeared in the
comics and is the name implies as you probably
guessed is the exact same effect when Hank
Pym Antman became giant man the comics.
Maybe we'll see live-action MCU hope van dyne
go giant during Antman three quantumania.
This also the idea of Cassie Lang stature
and one of her trademark abilities is going
giant in their doing Cassie link stature during
ant-man three then Kurt makes the Bobby agar
reference again but this time talking about
the which the myth it is a reference to zombie
scarlet witch showing up to attack them.
They do a bunch of jump scared jokes was Spider-Man
making more horror movie references talk about
jump scares just as vision then comes in jump
scares them again.
He explains how he's not in any danger, because
he is not made of human flesh and he explains
the effect that the mind stone has holding
the other zombies at bay if it wasn't clear
he was not lying or misleading them about
the actual mind stone care it was just that
he was doing really terrible, terrible things
feeding Black Panther in other avengers to
zombie scarlet witch while he was developing
a cure he banner go all science pros together
while they explain the quantum virus and they
reveal how he was able to successfully use
it on Scott Lang turning his head back in
a normal which is how we get to head in a
jar ant-man which is kind of the Futurama
reference.
He makes a ton of head in a jar jokes I've
lost weight don't worry, I won't let it go
to my head.
Like is that is kind of wall-to-wall puns
from ant-man for the rest of the episode,
they explain their plan to broadcast visions
mind stone cure from Wakanda using their satellite
technology, because it's so advanced which
a coy a confirms is the last human sanctuary
on earth because of the superior shield technology
turns out.
They did not plan on a zombie thanos with
an infinity gauntlet though they reveal the
big twist about him keeping Black Panther
their feeding bits of him to zombie scarlet
witch like he's lost his leg already scarlet
witch breaks free they reveal she hasn't eaten
in days and she goes full Baba Yaga eating
Kurt as he talks about Baba Yaga.
The cloak of levitation winds up saving Scott
Lang so he kind of becomes a floating head
in a jar for the rest of the episode and to
his credit, even though he's clearly gone
nuts with love for scarlet witch vision does
help them escape and winds up sacrificing
himself ripping the mind stone out so they
can take it to Wakanda and theoretically use
it to broadcast the signal.
So that's why he ripped it out, because he
didn't want to leave scarlet witch killing
himself the same way that thanos killed him
during avengers Infinity War ripping the mind
stone out Scott Lang makes a Harry Potter
referencing when guardian love Llosa a coy
a then sacrifices herself to scarlet witch
to help them escape going out with a big Wakanda
forever because scarlet witch is so powerful
and the zombie horde is coming in on them
winter soldier then has to sacrifice himself
the slow them down she's is a she puns them
a couple miles out of the way.
But when she sees vision said body.
She does pause for second and seemed kind
of sad.
I she registers some emotion.
So even though she's turned she does have
some of her human emotions left.
But this is actually meant to be a reference
to the original ending from avengers Infinity
War you may have seen this deleted scene of
done a video for to my channel so I'll post
a link for that in the description.
But during avengers Infinity War originally
banner was supposed to hulk out from inside
the hulkbuster at the end of that final boss
fight and Wakanda it would've been him turning
into Prof. hulk for the first time sort of
like the halfway combine version of falcon
banner the actually film the scene legit and
release it later is a deleted scene Spider-Man
references the rules of horror movies again
when one of them says we've escaped prematurely
giant zombie hope van dyne attacking them
midair and when Scott laying says that's twice
she save me the first time was during the
first Ant-Man movie and we get to see some
really solid Spider-Man Black Panther scenes
in you do feel kind of heartbroken that were
never going to get to see a version of this
play out in the live action marvel movies
like will never get to see tom Holland's Spider-Man
share scenes with Chadwick postman's Black
Panther but he references his same speech
from Captain America Civil War about death
not being the end and Wakanda culture talking
about the ancestral plane the big twist ending
probably one of the biggest moments of the
episode, they reveal that thanos has already
invaded Wakanda where they're headed having
been turned into a zombie himself and he has
all the infinity stones except the mind stone
which they are now conveniently bringing to
him without realizing it.
So when the watcher says that they're trying
to save their plan at the cost of dooming the universe
There referencing the snap, but because it's
zombie thanos they're implying that his snap
will turn the entire universe into marvel
zombies perfectly balanced is all zombie universes should be
But if you spotted any other big Easter eggs
or references in the episode that I didn't
mention in the video just right them blown
the comments in my full what if episode 6
video will post next week on Wednesday just
like normal links for all my what if episode
videos down in the description below and there's
a bunch of big trailers coming up this week
to like the matrix 4 trailer I'll do a video
for that tomorrow make sure you have alerts
enabled so you don't miss that.
I got a couple more big shang chi videos and
Avengers 5 videos, because that post credit
scene that I'm working on those will post
really soon to everyone click here for my
shang chi post credit scene video and everyone
click here for my full breakdown and Easter
eggs for the entire shang chi movie the you
so much for watching everyone stay safe and
I'll see you guys next video!